foreign
is with us in Tampa hi Mary welcome to
the Ramsey Show
what's up
so um I don't know where I should start
but um I've got over 85 000 with a debt
with my husband
um that we've incurred over probably the
last 15 years been having trouble paying
it off
um so we're married for now I'm not sure
how much longer because I talked to a
lawyer uh he calls him a schmuck
basically
um I've got a lawyer or your husband
the lawyer calls my husband a schmuck oh
that's nice I know isn't that beautiful
um I have a high school graduate that's
going to college in August I have a
special we have a special niece daughter
who's 13 years old
um and I didn't work for like eight
years but I went back about seven years
ago and I worked my way up
um and I'm making about 75 000 right now
and he's finally
um he had his own business not doing
anything lost our butts trying to sell
our house
um and you know using our profits to pay
off all the debt from from his business
but he finally he has a job a stable job
in the past year and a half
um so I'm trying to figure out how to
pay off or how we're supposed to pay off
this debt um and
and gracefully exit out of the marriage
we had to we're renting it now because
we sold we sold our house we don't have
it let me stop you a second okay
um how long have you been married
um say 17 18 years I'm sorry longer than
that 24 my bad 24 years yeah last track
why is your marriage over
it's been mentally checked out for
some time for many many years he worked
a lot
um worked a lot trying to make money
still in the beginning and
um mentally nothing and then the
lockdown hit and we were able to stop
some some of the pain of not having
money but I've been working so
um and a year ago he told me he had a
relationship with someone and so that's
basically I was I was waiting for the
schmuck party have you filed yet have
you filed for the divorce yet no no I
just I I just I can't afford to like I
don't know I'm in Tampa things are just
everything's ridiculously expensive and
I can't I've been looking to see you
know what what my options are but I
can't afford to like live alone right
now
didn't you say you make 75 000 a year
I do people make 75 000 a year live up
by themselves all the time in Tampa
that's above average
they don't live in your neighborhood
but they live I already lived out of
yeah but we lived out of the
neighborhood we live on the French so to
save money because rents were about a
thousand dollars more where we were at
yeah
when you talk to your lawyer when you
talk to your lawyer about this have you
done any research to find out what the
cost is what might happen with your debt
that sort of thing I don't know yeah I
don't know what happens with the debt
and I'm not sure if I remember asking
him about the debt
um I just know that everything else is
no fault so basically we just kind of
walk away it's not like one of us makes
more than the other person right now
um and
she wants my husband wants to
consolidate the debt
um
so it's 85 000 in credit card debt we
paid off our HELOC and all this other
stuff we had when we sold our house so
we were pretty much left with nothing
you have to refilled our house
okay and I guess all the credit card
debt is in both of your names
yeah the one cards in his and tour in
mine
but is it about half
yeah
the two that you have are about forty
two five
uh yeah 30 throughout all 30 across the
board
and this is hard making the payments
okay so you're 75 000 a year single mom
that has 38 000 in credit card debt
after the divorce right and you have a
special needs child
yes and he should hypothetically be
paying child support
I don't know yeah for him yeah my other
daughter's gone now or she's 18 now yeah
so hypothetically he'd have child
support in the special needs child right
yes okay
and um so you're I'm sorry this is a
very sad situation it is
um but you're not
mathematically trapped
mm-hmm lots of people make 75 000 a year
in the Tampa area that if Thirty thirty
eight thousand dollars in credit card
debt in one kit
lots of people I know we really hope
that we have a lot of Health expenses
because my older daughter actually has
more hold this his more health issues
than my younger daughter and my special
needs daughter for both you actually
yeah so we're constantly running the
doctors doing surgery he's doing
different things
uh car repairs and just the debt it just
you know that's not going to change
yeah
you're not stuck mathematically
you're not if you want to be you can
decide you are but the numbers you've
given us have not got you stuck in this
and uh if he's having Affairs and you're
going to end the marriage based on that
then you're going to have half of the
credit card debt
and you're going to have the care of a
child and you make seventy five thousand
dollars a year and you're going to go
rent an apartment
I think this I think what I'm hearing is
you've never been in a situation where
money is managing where money is being
managed effectively right and now you're
about to go off on your own and you
don't have the confidence of knowing
I can take the 75 000 a year and I can
manage it effectively it can be because
it's never been enough before right so
you don't know like inside your body you
don't know that this is going to be
enough that I'm going to be able to take
care of my kids that I'm going to be
able to pay the bills and I'm going to
be able to pay this debt up you don't
know that that's I mean you understand
that the story you told us as you all
mathematically in with him working and
earning you working and earning in the
best place you've been in probably a
decade mathematically you're in the best
place
relationally obviously relationally
obviously you're not the best place she
doesn't feel that she doesn't you don't
have any respect for him because he
didn't make any money during this time
he's a schmuck because he slept around
on you
um and so relationally you got those
things to overcome for this marriage to
survive if it's going to survive but
mathematically you're in the best place
you've ever been because you know with
his income if you if the marriage
survived with his income and your income
if you both decide to manage money
together you could clean this mess up
rather quickly
but I don't know we just resigned our
lease that's 2300 I mean that
where we're at that's like the cheapest
that we could get so we just renewed our
lease it doesn't sound like someone
that's filing for divorce to me
who's filing for divorce that re-signs a
new lease
for a year well I don't know I don't I
just I don't either who does that too
much going on mental I don't know I
think you just made a choice
yeah yeah she was like I have no choice
yeah I have no choice
but you felt like you had no choice but
you're taking your choices away but if
you want to be stuck out yeah you know
you can be stuck if you want to be but
you're not stuck
so um you know I I think that you guys
could sit down with a good marriage
counselor and invest some time and
energy into this 25-year marriage and
give this a shot since you just signed a
one-year lease I kind of think you want
to do that
deep down
and by the way if you ask a divorce
attorney if you're supposed to get a
divorce a hundred percent of the time
they say yes
like asking a dog if it's hungry